Welcome to lesson six. At this point, you guys can build
just about anything. You collect data from users. You can build pretty
web pages. You can store all of this stuff in databases. You
can manipulate this database. You can build log-ins, all sorts of cool
things. And when you think about it, just about every website
on the Internet is some combination of the things you've already learned
how to do. So it's pretty cool that you can, you've gotten
this far. Now, one of the things we haven't touched on yet,
is how to build websites that operate at a larger scale.
That is that more than just a couple of people can use.
When you start having websites operating at a big scale, lots
of things can break down. You can run out of disk space
for your data. You can run out of bandwidth, to serve
all of the amazing stuff that you have. Or you can run
out of you know, processor time to actually generate all of the
amazing computations you're doing. Right? There's
all sorts of different things that
can, that are limiting factors in how your website functions. And we're
going to learn how to address each of those things. How to use
multiple machines if you need to, and that sort of thing. So
that you can actually build a large-scale website. So, let's jump right in.